are you uncomfortable talking about this
yeah I mean it's pretty wild right
Mustafa Suleiman the billionaire founder
of Google's AI technology he's played a
key role in the development of AI from
its first critical steps in 2020 I moved
to work on Google's chatbot it was the
ultimate technology we can use them to
turbocharge our knowledge unlike
anything else why didn't they release it
we were nervous we were nervous every
organization is going to race to get
their hands on intelligence and that's
going to be incredibly destructive this
technology can be used to identify
cancerous tumors as it can to identify a
Target on the battlefield a tiny group
of people who wish to cause harm are
gonna have access to tools that can
instantly destabilize our world that's
the challenge how to stop something that
can cause harm or potentially kill
that's where we need containment do you
think that it is containable it has to
be possible why it must be possible why
must it be because otherwise it contains
us yet you chose to build a company in
this space why did you do that because I
want to design an AI That's on your side
I honestly think that if we succeed
everything is a lot cheaper it's going
to power New forms of transportation
reduce the cost of healthcare but what
if we fail the really painful answer to
that question is that
do you ever get sad about it
yeah it's intense
I think this is fascinating I looked at
the back end of our YouTube channel and
it says that since this channel started
69.9 of you that watch it frequently
haven't yet hit the Subscribe button so
I have a favor to ask you if you've ever
watched this Channel and enjoyed the
content if you're enjoying this episode
right now please could I ask a small
favor please hit the Subscribe button
helps this channel more than I can
explain and I promise if you do that to
return the favor we will make this show
better and better and better and better
and better that's the promise I'm
willing to make you if you hit the
Subscribe button do we have a deal
[Music]
everything that's going on with
artificial intelligence now and
um this new wave and all these times
like AGI and I saw another time in your
your book called ACI it's the first time
I'd heard that term how do you feel
about it emotionally if you had to
encapsulate how you feel emotionally
about what's going on in this moment how
would you do what words would you use I
would say
in the past
it would have been petrified
and I think that over time
as you really think through
the consequences and the pros and cons
and the trajectory that we're on
you adapt
and you understand that
actually there is something
incredibly inevitable about this
trajectory and that we have to wrap our
arms around it and guide it and control
it as a collective species as a as
Humanity
and I think the more you realize
how much influence we collectively can
have over this outcome the more
empowering it is because on the face of
it this is really going to be the tool
that helps us tackle all the challenges
that we're facing as a species right we
need to
fix water desalination we need to grow
food 100x cheaper than we currently do
we need renewable energy to be you know
ubiquitous and everywhere in our lives
we need to adapt to climate change
everywhere you look in the next 50 years
we have to do more with less
and there are very very few
proposals let alone practical solutions
for how we get there
training machines to help us as AIDS
scientific research Partners inventors
creators is absolutely essential and so
the upside is phenomenal it's enormous
but AI isn't just a thing it's not an
inevitable whole its form isn't
inevitable right it's form the exact way
that it manifests and appears in our
everyday lives and the way that it's
governed and who it's owned by and how
it's trained
that is a question
that is up to us collectively as a
species to figure out over the next
decade because if we don't Embrace that
challenge then it happens to us
and that's really what I'm I have been
wrestling with for 15 years of my career
is how to intervene in a way that this
really does benefit everybody and those
benefits far far outweigh the potential
risks at what stage were you petrified
so I found a deep mind in 2010
and
no over the course of the first few
years
our progress was fairly modest
but
quite quickly in sort of 2013 as the
Deep learning Revolution began to take
off
I could see glimmers
of very early versions of AIS learning
to do really clever things so for
example one of our big initial
achievements was to teach an AI to play
the Atari games so remember Space
Invaders and and pong where you bat a
ball from left to right
and we trained this initial AI to purely
look at the raw pixels screen by screen
flickering or moving in front of the AI
and then control the actions up down
left right shoot or not
and it got so good at learning to play
this simple game simply through
attaching a value between the reward
like it was it was getting score and
taking an action that it learned some
really clever strategies uh to play the
game really well that Us games players
and humans hadn't really even noticed or
at least people in the office haven't
noticed it some professionals did
um and that was amazing to me because I
was like wow this simple system that
learns through a set of stimuli plus a
reward to take some actions
can actually discover many strategies
clever tricks to play the game well that
us humans
haven't occurred to us right and that to
me is both thrilling
because it presents the opportunity to
invent new knowledge and Advance our
civilization
but of course in the same measure is
also
petrifying
was there a particular moment when you
were you were at deepmind where you go
whether you had that kind of Eureka
Moment Like a day when something
happened and it caused that
that Epiphany I guess was it yeah it it
was actually a moment even before 2013
where I remember standing in the office
and watching a very early prototype of
one of these image recognition image
generation models
that was trained to generate new
handwritten black and white digits so
imagine zero to one two three four five
six seven eight nine
all in different style of handwriting on
a tiny grid of like 300 pixels by 300
pixels in black and white
and we were trying to train the AI to
generate a new version of one of those
digits a number seven in a new
handwriting sounds so simplistic today
given the incredible photorealistic
images that are being generated right
um and I just remember so clearly it it
took sort of 10 or 15 seconds and it
just resolved it that the number
appeared it went from complete Black to
like slowly gray and then suddenly these
were like white pixels appeared out of
the the black darkness and it revealed a
number seven
and that sounds so simplistic in
hindsight but it was amazing I was like
wow
the model
kinda understands the representation of
a seven well enough to generate a new
example of a number seven
an image of a number seven
you know and you roll forward 10 years
and our predictions were correct in fact
it was quite predictable
in hindsight the trajectory that we were
on more compute plus vast amounts of
data has enabled us within a decade to
go from predicting black and white
digits
generating new versions of those images
to now generating unbelievable
photorealistic not just images but
videos novel videos
with a simple natural language
instruction or a prompt
what has surprised you you said you
referred to that as predictable but what
has surprised you about what's happened
over the last decade
so
I think what was predictable to me back
then was the generation of images and of
audio
um because the structure of an image is
locally contained so pixels that are
near one another create straight lines
and edges and corners and then
eventually they create eyebrows and
noses and eyes and faces and entire
scenes and I could just intuitively in a
very simplistic way I could get my head
around the fact that okay well we're
predicting these number sevens you can
imagine how you then can expand that out
to entire images maybe even to videos
maybe you know to audio too you know
what I said you know a couple seconds
ago is connected in phoneme space in the
spectrogram
but what was much more surprising to me
was that those same methods for
Generation applied in the space of
language
you know language seems like such a
different abstract space of ideas when I
say like the cat sat on the
most people would probably predict Matt
right but it could be table car chair
tree it could be Mountain Cloud I mean
there's a gazillion possible
next word predictions
and so the space is so much larger the
ideas are so much more abstract I just
couldn't wrap my intuition around the
idea that we would be able to create the
incredible large language models that
you see today
you check gpts
chat GPT
the Google's Bard inflection my new
company has an AI called Pi a pi dot AI
which stands for personal intelligence
and it's as good as chat GPT but much
more emotional empathetic and kind
so it's just super surprising to me that
just growing the size of these large
language models as we have done by 10x
every single year for the last 10 years
we've been able to produce this and that
that's just an amazingly large number if
you just kind of pause for a moment to
Grapple with the numbers here
in 2013 when we trained the Atari AI
that I mentioned to you at deepmind
that used two Peta flops of computation
so peta peta stands for a million
billion calculations a flop is a
calculation so two million billion
right which is already an insane number
of calculations it's totally crazy yeah
just two of these units that are already
really large
and every year since then we've 10xed
the number of calculations that can be
done such that today
the biggest language model that we train
at inflection uses 10 billion petaflops
so 10 billion million billion
calculations I mean it's just
unfathomably large number
and what we've really observed is that
scaling these models by 10x every single
year
produces this magical experience of
talking to an AI that feels like you're
talking to a human that is super
knowledgeable and super smart
there's so much that's happened in
public conversation around AI um and
there's so many questions that I have
I've I've been speaking to a few people
about artificial intelligence to try and
understand it and
I'm I think where I am right now is I
feel quite scared
um but when I get scared I don't get
it's not the type of scared that makes
me anxious it's not like an emotional
scared it's a very logical scared it's
my very logical brain hasn't been able
to figure out how the inevitable outcome
that I've arrived at which is that
humans become the less dominant species
on this planet
um how that is to be avoided in any way
the first chapter of your book The
Coming wave is a is is a is
titled
appropriately to how I feel containment
is not possible
you say in that chapter the widespread
emotional reaction I I was observing is
something I've come to call the
pessimism aversion trap correct what is
the pessimism aversion trap
well
so all of us be included
feel what you just described when you
first get to grips with the idea of this
new coming wave it's scary it's
petrifying it's threatening is it going
to take my job is my daughter or son
gonna fall in love with it you know what
does this mean what does it mean to be
human in a world where there's these
other human-like things that aren't
human how do I make sense of that it's
super scary
and a lot of people over the last few
years
I think things have changed in the last
six months I have to say but over the
last few years
I would say the default reaction has
been to avoid the pessimism and the fear
right to just kind of recoil from it and
pretend that it's like either not
happening or that it's all going to work
out to be Rosy it's going to be fine we
don't have to worry about it people
often say well we've always created new
jobs we've never permanently displaced
jobs we've only ever seen new jobs be
created unemployment is an all-time low
right so there's this default optimism
bias that we have and I think it's less
about a need for optimism and more about
a fear of pessimism
and so that trap
particularly in Elite circles means that
often we aren't having the tough
conversations that we need to have in
order to respond to the coming wave
are you scared in part about having
those tough conversations because of how
it might be received
um not so much anymore so I've spent
most of my career
trying to put those tough questions on
the policy table right I've been raising
these questions the ethics of AI safety
and questions of containment for as long
as I can remember with governments and
civil societies and all the rest of it
and so I've become used to talking about
that and
you know I think
it's
essential that we have the honest
conversation because we can't let it
happen to us we have to openly talk
about it
is
I mean this is a this is a big a big
question but
as you sit here now do you think that it
is containable because I
I can't see how
I can't see how it can be contained
chapter three is the containment problem
are you giving give the example of how
Technologies are often invented for good
reasons and for certain use cases like
the hammer you know which is used you
know maybe to build something but it
also can be used to kill people
um
and you say in history we haven't been
able to ban a technology ever
really it has always found a way into
society
um because of other societies have an
incentive to have it even if we don't
and then we need we need it like the
nuclear bomb because if they have it
then we don't then we're at disadvantage
so are you optimistic
honestly
I don't think
an optimism or a pessimism frame
is the right one because the E both are
equally biased in ways that
I think distract us
as I say in the book on the face of it
it does look like containment isn't
possible we haven't contained or
permanently banned a technology of this
type in the past there are some that we
have done right so we banned CFCs for
example because they were producing a
hole in the ozone layer we've banned
certain weapons chemical and biological
weapons for example or blinding lasers
Believe It or Not There are such things
as lasers that were instantly blind you
you know so we have stepped back from
the frontier
in some cases but that's largely where
there's either cheaper or you know
equally effective Alternatives that are
quickly adopted in this case these
Technologies are Omni use so the same
core technology can be used to identify
you know cancerous tumors in chest
x-rays as it can to identify a Target on
the battlefield for an aerial strike so
that mixed use or Omni use
is going to drive the proliferation
because there's huge commercial
incentives because it's going to deliver
a huge benefit and do a lot of good
and that's the challenge that we have to
figure out is how to stop something
which on the face of it is so good but
at the same time can be used in really
bad ways too
do you think we will
I do think we will so I think that
nation states Remain the backbone of our
civilization we have
chosen to concentrate power
in a single Authority the nation-state
and we pay our taxes and we've given the
nation-state a monopoly over the use of
violence
and now the nation-state is going to
have to
update itself quickly to be able to
contain this technology because without
that kind of
essentially oversight both of those of
us who are making it but also crucially
of the open source
then it will proliferate and it will
spread but regulation is still a real
tool and we can use it and we must what
does what does the world look like in
um let's say 30 years if that doesn't
happen in your view
people because people the average person
can't really grapple their head around
artificial intelligence when they think
of it they think of like these large
language models that you can chat to and
ask it about your homework
that's like the average person's
understanding of artificial intelligence
because that's all they've ever been
exposed to of it you have a different
View
because of the work you've spent the
last decade doing so to try and give
Dave
who's I don't know an Uber driver in
Birmingham an idea who's listening to
this right now what artificial
intelligence intelligence is and its
potential capabilities if
you know there's no there's no
containment what does it what does the
world look like in 30 years
so I think it's going to feel largely
like another human
so think about the things that you can
do
not again in the physical world but in
the digital world 2050 I'm thinking of
I'm in 2050.
2050 we will have robots
2050 we will definitely have robots I
mean more than that 2050 we will have
new biological beings as well
because the same trajectory that we've
been on with hardware and software is
also going to apply to the platform of
biology are you uncomfortable talking
about this yeah I mean it's pretty wild
right it donates you cross your arms
no I always I always look I always I
always use that as a key for someone
when a subject matter is uncomfortable
and it's interesting because I know you
know so much more than me
and about this and I know you've spent
way more hours thinking off into the
future about the consequences of this I
mean you've written a book about it so
yeah like you spent 10 years at the very
deep mine is one of the the Pinnacle
companies the Pioneers in this whole
Space
so you know you know some stuff and it's
funny because when I was I watched an
interview with Elon Musk and he was
asked a question similar to this I know
he speaks in certain
sentence had a voice but he said that he
he's almost he's gotten to the point
where he thinks he's living in suspended
disbelief
where he thinks that if he spent too
long thinking about it he wouldn't
understand the purpose of what he's
doing right now and he he says that it's
more dangerous than nuclear weapons um
and that it's too late too late to stop
it this one interview that's chilling
and I was filming Dragons Den the other
day and I showed the dragons the clip I
was like look what Elon Musk said when
he was asked about what his child what
advice he should give to his children in
a world of in an inevitable world of
artificial intelligence it's the first
time I've seen Elon Musk stop for like
20 seconds and not know what to say
stumble stumble stumble stumble stumble
and then conclude that he's living in
suspended disbelief yeah I mean I think
it's a great phrase
that is the moment we're in we have to
it's what I said to you about the
pessimism's aversion trap we have to
confront
the probability of seriously dark
outcomes and we have to spend time
really thinking about those consequences
because the competitive nature of
companies and of nation states is going
to mean that every organization is going
to race to get their hands on
intelligence intelligence is going to be
a new form of of capital right just as
there was a grab for land or there's a
grab for oil there's a grab for anything
that enables you to do more with less
faster better smarter right and we can
clearly see the predictable trajectory
of the exponential improvements in these
Technologies and so we should expect
that wherever there is power there's now
a new tool to amplify that power
accelerate that power Turbo Charge it
right and you know in 2050 if you asked
me to look out there
I mean of course it makes me Grimace
that's why I was like oh my God it's
it really does feel like a new species
and and that has to be brought under
control we cannot allow ourselves to be
dislodged from our position as the
dominant species on this planet we
cannot allow that
you mentioned robots so these are sort
of adjacent technologies that are rising
with artificial intelligence robots you
mentioned
um biological new biological species
give me some light on what you mean by
that
well so so far the dream of Robotics
hasn't really come to fruition right I
mean we're we still have the most we
have now are sort of drones and a little
bit of self-driving cars
but that is broadly on the same
trajectory as these other Technologies
and I think that over the next 30 Years
you know we are going to have humanoid
robotics we're going to have
um you know physical
tools within our everyday system that
we can rely on that will be pretty good
that'll be pretty good to do many of the
physical tasks and that's a little bit
further out because I think it you know
there's a lot of tough problems there
but it's still coming in the same way
and likewise with Biology you know we
can now sequence a genome for a
millionth of the cost
of the first genome which took place in
2000 so 20-ish years ago
the cost has come down by a million
times and we can now increasingly
synthesize that is create or manufacture
new bits of DNA which obviously
give rise to life in every possible form
and we're starting to engineer that DNA
to either remove traits or capabilities
that we don't like or indeed to add new
things that we want it to do we want you
know fruit to last longer or we want
meat to have higher protein etc etc
synthetic meat to have higher protein
levels
and what's the implications of that
well potential implications
I think that the darkest scenario there
is that people will experiment with
pathogens
engineered
you know synthetic pathogens that might
end up accidentally or intentionally
being more transmissible
I.E they they can spread faster
or more lethal I.E you know they cause
more harm or potentially kill like a
pandemic like a pandemic
um and
that's where we need containment right
we have to limit access to the tools and
the know-how to carry out that kind of
experimentation so one framework of
thinking about this with respect to
making containment possible
is that
we really are experimenting with
dangerous materials and Anthrax is not
something that can be bought over the
Internet that can be freely experimented
with and likewise the very best of these
tools in a few years time are going to
be capable of creating
you know new synthetic
pandemic pathogens and so we have to
restrict access to those things that
means restricting access to the compute
it means restricting access to the
software that runs the models to the
cloud environments that provide apis
provide you access to experiment with
those things and of course on the
biology side it means restricting access
to some of the substances and people
aren't going to like this
people are not going to like
that claim because it means that those
who want to do good with those tools
those who want to create a startup the
small guy the little developer that
struggles to comply with all the
regulations they're going to be pissed
off understandably right but that is the
age we're in
deal with it like we have to confront
that reality that means that we have to
approach this with the precautionary
principle right never before in the
invention of a technology or in the
creation of a regulation have we
proactively said we need to go slowly we
need to make sure that this first does
no harm the precautionary principle and
that is just an unprecedented moment no
other Technology's done that right
because I think
we collectively in the industry those of
us who are closest to the work can see a
place in five years or ten years
where it could get out of control and we
have to get on top of it now and it's
better to forgo like that is give up
some of those potential upsides or
benefits until we can be more sure
that it can be contained that it can be
controlled that it always serves our
Collective interests
think about that so I think about what
you've just said there about being able
to create these pathogens these diseases
and viruses Etc that you know could
become weapons or whatever else but with
artificial intelligence and the power of
that intelligence with these um
pathogens
you could theoretically ask one of these
systems to create a virus
that
a very deadly virus
um you could ask the artificial
intelligence to create a very deadly
virus that has certain properties
um
maybe even that mutates over time in a
certain way so it only kills a certain
amount of people kind of like a nuclear
bomb of viruses that you could just pop
hit an enemy with now if I'm if I hear
that and I go okay that's powerful
I would like one of those you know there
might be an adversary out there that
goes I would like one of those just in
case America get out of hand in America
is thinking you know I want one of those
in case Russia gets out of hand
and so okay you might take a
precautionary approach in the United
States but that's only going to put you
on the back foot when China or Russia or
one of your adversaries accelerates
forward in that in that path and it's
the same with the the nuclear bomb and
you know you nailed it I mean that is
the race condition we refer to that as
the race condition the idea that if I
don't do it the other party is gonna do
it and therefore I must do it but the
problem with that is that it creates a
self-fulfilling prophecy so the default
there is that we all end up doing it and
that can't be right because there is a
opportunity for massive cooperation here
there's a shared that is between us and
China and every other quote unquote them
or they or enemy that we want to create
we've all got a shared interest
in advancing the collective health and
well-being of humans and Humanity how
well have we done it promoting shared
interest well in the development of
Technologies over the years even at like
a corporate level even you know
you know the nuclear non-proliferation
treaty has been reasonably successful
there's only nine nuclear states in the
world today we've stopped many like
three countries actually gave up nuclear
weapons because we incentivized them
with sanctions and threats and economic
rewards
um small groups have tried to get access
to nuclear weapons and so far have
largely failed it's expensive though
right and hard to like uranium as a as a
chemical to keep it stable and to to buy
it and to house it I mean I can just put
it in the shed you certainly couldn't
put it in a shed you can't download
uranium 235 off the Internet it's not
available open source that is totally
true so it's got different
characteristics for sure but a kid in
Russia could you know in his bedroom
could download something onto his
computer that's
incredibly harmful in the in artificial
intelligence Department right
I think that that will be possible at
some point in the next five years it's
true because there's a weird Trend
that's going on here on the one hand
You've Got The Cutting Edge
AI models that are built by Google and
open Ai and my company inflection and
they cost hundreds of millions of
dollars and there's only a few of them
but on the other hand the what was
cutting edge a few years ago is now open
source today so gpt3 which came out in
the summer of 2020
is now
reproduced as an open source model so
the code and the weights of the model
the design of the model and the actual
implementation code is completely freely
available on the web and it's tiny it's
like 60 times or 60 70 times smaller
than the original model which means that
it's cheaper to use and cheaper to run
and that's as you know we've said
earlier like that's the natural
trajectory of technologies that become
useful they get more efficient they get
cheaper and they spread further and so
that's the containment challenge that's
really the essence of
well I'm sort of trying to raise in my
book is to frame the challenge of the
next 30 to 50 years as a round
containment and around confronting
proliferation
do you believe because we're both going
to be alive unless there's you know some
robot kills us but we're both going to
be 11 30 years time
I hope so maybe the podcast will still
be going unless AI is now taking my job
it's very possible so I'm going to sit
you here and you know when you're I mean
you'll be in what 60 68 years old I'll
be 60.
um
and I'll say
at that point when we have that
conversation do you think we would have
been successful in containment on a
global level
I think we have to be I can't even think
that we're not why
because I'm fundamentally a humanist
and I think that we have to make a
choice
to put our species first
and
I think that that's what we have to be
defending for the next 50 years that's
what we have to defend because look it
it's it's certainly possible that we
invent these agis in such a way that
they are always going to be provably
um subservient uh to humans and take
instructions you know from their human
controller every single time
but enough of us think that we can't be
sure about that
that I don't think we should take the
gamble basically so
that's why I think that we should focus
on containment and non-proliferation
because some people if they do have
access to the technology will want to
take those risks and they will just want
to see like what's on the other side of
the door you know and they might end up
opening Pandora's Box and that's a
decision that affects all of us
and that's the challenge of the
networked age you know we live in this
globalized world and we use these words
like globalization and we you sort of
forget what globalization means this is
what globalization is this is what a
networked world is it means that someone
taking one small action can suddenly
spread everywhere instantly regardless
of their intentions when they took the
action it may be
you know unintentional like you say it
may be that they're never they weren't
ever meaning to do harm
when I think I asked you when I said it
in 30 years time you said that there
will be like human
level intelligence you'll be interacting
with
you know this new species but the
species
for me to think the species were one to
interact with me is
feels like wishful thinking because what
will I be to them you know like I've got
a French Bulldog Pablo and I can't
imagine our IQ is that far apart like
you know in relatives terms my the IQ
between me and my dog Pablo I can't
imagine that's that far apart even when
I think about is it like the orangutan
where we only have like one percent
difference in DNA or something crazy and
yet they throw their poop around and I'm
sat here broadcasting around the world
there's quite a difference in that one
percent you know
and then I think about this new species
where as you write in your book in
chapter four
there seems to be no upper limit to ai's
potential intelligence
why would such an intelligence want to
interact with me
well it depends how you design it so
I think that our goal one of the
challenges of containment is to design
AIS that we want to interact with that
want to interact with us right if you
set an objective function for an AI a
goal for an AI by its design
which you know inherently disregards or
disrespects you as a human and your
goals then it's going to wander off and
do a lot of strange things whatever has
kids and the kids
you know what I mean what if it
replicates in a way where because
because I've I've heard this this
conversation around like it depends how
we design it but you know
I think about
it's kind of like if I have a kid and
the kid grows up to be a thousand times
more intelligent than me
to think that I can have any influence
on it on it when it's a thinking
sentient
developing
species again feels like
I'm overestimating my version of
intelligence and importance and
significance in the face of something
that is incomprehensibly like even a
hundred times more intelligent than me
and the speed of its computation is a
thousand times what my
the meat in my skull can do yeah like
how how is it gonna how how do I know
it's gonna respect me or care about me
or understand you know that I may you
know
I think that comes back down to the
containment challenge I think that if we
can't be confident
that it's going to respect you and
understand you and work for you and us
as a species overall
then that's where we have to adopt the
precautionary principle I don't think we
should be taking those kinds of risks in
experimentation and design and now I'm
not saying it's possible to design an AI
that doesn't have those self-improvement
capabilities in the limit in like 30 or
50 years I think it you know that's kind
of what I was saying is like it seems
likely that if you have one like that
it's going to take advantage of infinite
amounts of data and Infamous amounts of
computation and it's going to kind of
outstrip our ability
to act and so I think we have to step
back from that precipice that's what
the containment problem is is that it's
it's actually saying no sometimes it's
saying no and
that's a different sort of muscle that
we've never really exercised as a
civilization and that's obviously why
containment appears not to be possible
because we've never done it before we've
never done it before and every inch of
our you know Commerce and politics and
our war and our all of our instincts are
just like Clash complete Clash compete
profit profit grow beat exactly dominate
you know fear them be paranoid like now
all this nonsense about like China being
this new evil like it how does that slip
into our culture how are we suddenly all
shifted from thinking it's the the
Muslim terrorists about to blow us all
up to now it's the Chinese who are about
to you know blow up Kansas it's just
like what
about like we really have to pair back
the paranoia and the fear and the
othering
um because those are the incentive
dynamics that are going to drive us to
you know cause self-harm to humanity
thinking the worst of each other there's
a couple of key moments when in my
understanding of artificial intelligence
that have been kind of Paradigm Paradigm
shifts for me because I think like many
people I thought of artificial
intelligence as
you know like a like a child I was
Raising and I would program I would code
it to do certain things so I'd code it
to play chess and I would tell it the
moves that are conducive with being
successful in chess and then I remember
watching that like alphago documentary
right which I think was deep deep mind
that was us yeah you guys so you
programmed this this um artificial
intelligence to play the game go which
is kind of like just think of it kind of
like a chess or a black cam or whatever
and it eventually just beats the best
player in the world of all time and it
and the way it learned how to beat the
best player in the world of all time the
world champion he was by the way
depressed when he got beat
um was just by playing itself right
and then there's this moment I think is
it game four or something right right it
does this move that no one could have
predicted right it's a move that
seemingly makes absolutely no sense
right
in those moments where no one trained it
to do that and it did something
unexpected Beyond where humans are
trying to figure it out in hindsight
this is where I go how do you how do you
train it if it's doing things we didn't
anticipate right
like how do you control it when it's
doing things that humans couldn't
anticipate it doing well we're looking
at that move it's called like move 37
correct yeah is it move 37 it is nice
intelligence nice work yeah a bit longer
than I thought it's like 30. so at least
another decade
um move 37 does this crazy thing and you
see everybody like lean in and go why
has it done that and it turns out to be
brilliant that humans couldn't couldn't
afford the commentator actually thought
it was a mistake yeah he was a pro and
he was like this is definitely a mistake
you know it's the alphagos lost the game
but it was so far ahead of us that I
knew something we didn't right right
that's when that's when I lost hope in
this whole idea of like oh train it to
do what we want like a dog like sit pour
roll over right
well the real challenge is that we
actually wanted to do those things like
when it discovers a new strategy or it
invents a new idea or it helps us find
like you know a cure for some disease
right that's why we're building it right
because we're reaching the limits
of what we as you know humans can invent
and solve right especially with what
we're facing of you know in terms of
population growth over the next 30 Years
and how climate change is going to
affect that and so on like
we really want these tools to
turbocharge us right and yet like it's
that creativity and that invention which
obviously makes us also feel
well
maybe it it is really going to do things
that we don't like for sure right
how do you contend with all of this how
do you contend with the
the clear-up side and then you must like
Elon must be completely aware of the
the horrifying existential risk at the
same time and you're building a big
company in this space which I think is
valued at 4 billion now inflection AI
which has got this its own
model called pi
so you're building in this space you
understand the incentives that both the
nation-state level and a corporate level
that we're going to keep playing forward
even if the US stops there's going to be
some other country that sees that as a
huge Advantage their economy will swell
because they did
if this company stops then this one's
gonna get a get a huge advantage and
then shareholders are you know
everyone's investing in AI full steam
ahead
but you feel you can see this huge
existential risk is it suspended is that
the password suspended disbelief
I mean just kind of like just know that
it's I feel like I know that's going to
happen
no one's been able to tell me otherwise
but just don't think too much about it
and you'll be okay
I think you can't give up
right I think that in some ways
your realization exactly what you've
just described like weighing up
two conflicting and horrible truths
about what is likely to happen those
contradictions
that is a kind of honesty and a wisdom I
think that we need all collectively to
realize because the only path through
this is to
be straight up and embrace you know the
risks and embrace the default trajectory
of all these competing incentives
driving forward to kind of make this
feel like inevitable and if you put the
blinkers on and you kind of just ignore
it or if you just be super Rosy and it's
all going to be all right and if you say
that we've always figured out anyway
then we're not going to get the energy
and the dynamism and engagement from
everybody to try to figure this out and
that's what gives me like reason to be
hopeful because I think that we make
progress by getting everybody paying
attention to this it isn't going to be
about those who are currently the AI
scientists or those who are the
technologists or you know like me or the
Venture capitalists or just the
politicians like all of those people no
one's got answers so that's what we have
to confront there are no obvious answers
to this profound question
and I've basically written the book to
say
prove that I'm wrong
you know containment must be possible
and I it must be it must be possible it
has to be possible it has to be you want
it to be I I desperately want it to be
yeah why must it be
because
otherwise I think you're in the camp of
believing that this is
the inevitable evolution of humans
the transhuman
kind of view
you know some people would argue like
what is okay let's part let's let's
stretch the timelines out okay so let's
not talk about 30 years
let's talk about 200 years
like what is this gonna look like in
you tell me you're smarter than me
I mean it's mind-blowing it's
mind-blowing we'll have quantum
computers by then what's a quantum
computer
a quantum computer is a completely
different type of computing architecture
which in simple terms
basically allows you to prove those
those calculations that I described at
the beginning billions and billions of
flops those billions of flops can be
done in a single computation
so everything that you see in the
digital world today relies on computers
processing information
and and the speed of that processing is
a friction it kind of slows things down
right you remember back in the day old
school modems 56k modem the dial-up
sound and the image pixel loading like
pixel by pixel that was because the
computers were slow and we're getting to
a point now where the computers are
getting faster and faster and faster and
Quantum Computing is like a whole new
leap like way way way Beyond where we
where we currently are and so by analogy
how would I understand that so like if
my I've got my dial-up modem over here
and then Quantum Computing over here
right
what's the how do I what's the
difference well I don't know what it's
really difficult to explain billion
times faster oh it's it's like it's like
billions of billions times faster it's
it's it's much more than that I mean one
way of thinking about it is like
a floppy disk which I guess most people
remember 1.4 megabytes a physical thing
back in the day
in 1960 or so
that was basically an entire pallet's
worth of computer that was moved around
by a forklift truck
right which is insane today you know you
have billions and billions of times that
floppy disk
in your smartphone in your pocket
tomorrow you're going to have
billions and billions of smartphones in
minuscule wearable devices there'll be
cheap fridge magnets that you know are
constantly on everywhere sensing all the
time
monitoring processing analyzing
improving optimizing
you know and they'll be super cheap
so
it's super unclear what do you do with
all of that knowledge and information I
mean it's ultimately knowledge
creates value when you know the
relationship between things you can
improve them you know make it more
efficient
and so more data is what has enabled us
to build all the value of you know
online in the last 25 years
and so what does that look like in 150
years I can't really even imagine to be
honest with you it's very hard to say I
don't think everybody is going to be
working
why would we yeah well
we wouldn't be working in that kind of
environment I mean look the other
trajectory to add to this
is the cost of energy production
you know AI if it really helps us solve
battery storage
which is the missing piece I think to
really tackle climate change
then we will be able to source
basically source and store
Infinite Energy
from the Sun
and I think in 20 or so years time 20 30
years time
that is going to be a cheap and widely
available if not completely freely
available resource and if you think
about it everything in life
has the cost of energy built into its
production value
and so if you strip that out
everything is likely to get a lot
cheaper we'll be able to desalinate
water we'll be able to grow crops much
much cheaper we were able to grow much
higher quality food right it's going to
power New forms of transportation it's
going to reduce the cost of drug
production and health care right so all
of those gains obviously there'll be a
huge commercial incentive to drive the
production of those gains but the cost
of producing them is going to go through
the floor I think that's one key thing
that a lot of people don't realize that
is a reason to be hugely hopeful and
optimistic about the future everything
is going to get radically cheaper in 30
to 50 years
hmm
so 200 years time we have no idea what
the world looks like it's uh this goes
back to the point about being is it did
you say transhumanist right what does
that mean
transhumanism
I mean it's a group of people who
basically believe that
you the the humans and our soul and our
being will one day transcend or move
beyond our biological substrate okay so
our physical body our brain our biology
is just an enabler for your intelligence
and who you are as a person and
there's a group of kind of crack Bots
basically I think who think that we're
going to be able to upload ourselves
to a silicon substrate right a computer
that can hold the essence of what it
means to be Stephen so you in 220 uh in
in 2200
well could well still be You by their
reasoning
but you'll live on a server somewhere
why are they wrong I think about all
these adjacent Technologies like
biological
um biological advancements did you call
it like biosynthesis or something yeah
synthetic biology synthetic biology
um I think about the nanotechnology
development right about Quantum
computing
the the progress in artificial
intelligence that everything becoming
cheap and I think why why are they wrong
it's hard to say precisely
but broadly speaking I haven't seen any
evidence yet that we're able to extract
the essence of a being from a brain
right it's that that is that that kind
of dualism that you know there is a mind
and a body and a spirit that is a I I
don't think I don't see much evidence
for that even in Neuroscience
um that actually it's much more one and
the same so I don't think you know
you're going to be able to emulate the
entire brain so their thesis is that or
some of them cryogenically store their
brain after death Jesus so they they
have it they've they wear these like you
know how you have like an organ donor
tag or whatever so they have a
cryogenically freeze me when I die tag
and so they there's like a special
ambulance services that will come pick
you up because obviously you need to do
it really quickly the moment you die you
need to get put into a cryogenic freezer
to preserve your you know brain forever
I personally think this is this is nuts
but you know their belief is that you'll
then be able to reboot that biological
brain and then transfer you over
um
it doesn't seem plausible to me when you
said at the start of this this little
topic here that you it must be possible
to contain it so it must be possible
um the reason why I I struggle with that
is because in chapter seven you say a
line in your book that AI is more
autonomous than any other technology in
history
for centuries the idea that
technologists is somehow running out of
control are self-directed and
self-propelling force beyond the Realms
of human agency remained a fiction not
any more
and this idea of autonomous technology
that is
acting un instructed
um and is intelligent and then you say
we must be able to contain it it's kind
of like a massive dog like a big
rottweiler yeah that is you know a
thousand times bigger than me and me
looking up at it and going I'm gonna
give take you for a walk yep yeah and
then it just looking down at me and just
stepping over me or stepping on me well
that's actually a good example because
we have actually contained Rottweilers
before we've contained gorillas and you
know tigers and crocodiles and pandemic
pathogens and nuclear weapons and so you
know it's easy to be you know a hater on
what we've achieved
but this is the most peaceful moment in
the history of our species this is a
moment when our biggest problem is that
people eat too much
think about that we've spent our entire
evolutionary period
running around looking for food and
trying to stop you know our enemies
throwing rocks at us
and we've had this incredible period of
500 years where you know each year
things have broadly were maybe each
each Century let's say there's been a
few ups and downs but things have
broadly got better and we're on a
trajectory for you know life spans to
increase and quality of life to increase
and health and well-being to improve and
I think that's because in many ways we
have succeeded in containing forces that
appear to be more powerful than
ourselves it just requires unbelievable
creativity and adaptation it requires
compromise and it requires a new
tone
right a much more humble tone to
governance and politics and and how we
run our world not this kind of like
hyper aggressive adversarial paranoia
tone that we talked about previously but
one that is like
much more wise than that much more
accepting that we are unleashing this
force that does have that potential to
be the Rottweiler that you described but
that we must
contain that as our number one priority
that has to be the thing that we focus
on because otherwise it contains us
I've been thinking a lot recently about
cyber security as well just broadly on
an individual level
in a world where there are these kinds
of tools which seems to be quite close
large language models it brings up this
whole new question about cyber security
and cyber safety and you know in a world
where there's um these ability to
generate audio and language and videos
that seem to be real
um
what can we trust and you know I was
watching a video of a
of a of a young girl whose grandmother
was called up by
a voice that was made to sound like her
son saying he'd been in a car accident
and asking for money
and her nearly sending the money or this
whole what you know because this really
brings into Focus that we our life is a
build on built on trust trusting the
things we see here and
watch and in in and now where it feels
like a
a moment where we're no longer going to
be able to trust what we see on the
internet on the phone
[Music]
what what advice do you do we you have
for people who are worried about this
um
so
skepticism I think is
healthy and necessary and I think that
we're going to need it
um even more than than we ever did right
and so if you think about how we've
adapted to the first wave of this which
was spammy email scams
um everybody got them and over time
people learn to identify them and be
skeptical of them and reject them
likewise you know I'm sure many of us
get like text messages I'd certainly get
loads of text messages trying to fish me
and ask me to meet up or do this that
and the other
and we've adapted right now I think
we should all know and expect that
criminals will use these tools to
manipulate us just as you described I
mean you know the voice is going to be
human-like the Deep fake is going to be
super convincing and there are actually
ways around those things so for example
the reason why the banks invented
OTP um one-time passwords where they
send you a text message with a special
code
um is precisely for this reason so that
you have a 2fa a two-factor
authentication increasingly we will have
a three or four Factor authentication
where you have to triangulate between
multiple separate independent sources
and it won't just be like call your bank
manager and release the funds right so
this is where we need the creativity and
energy and attention of everybody
because
defense the kind of defensive measures
have to evolve as quickly as the
potential offensive measures the attacks
that are coming
I heard you say this that you think um
some people are
for many of these problems we're going
to need to develop AIS to
Defenders from the AIS
right we kind of already have that right
so we have automated ways of detecting
spam online these days you know most of
the time there are machine Learning
Systems which are trying to identify
when your credit card is used in a
fraudulent way that's not a human
sitting there looking at patterns of
spending traffic in real time that's an
AI that is like flagging that something
looks off
um likewise with data centers or
security cameras a lot of those security
cameras these days are you know have
tracking algorithms that look for you
know surprising sounds or like if a if a
glass window is is smashed that will be
detected by an AI often that is you know
listening on the security camera
so you know that's kind of what I mean
by that is that increasingly those AIS
will get more capable and will want to
use them for defensive purposes and
that's exactly what it looks like to
have good healthy well-functioning
controlled AIS that serve us I went on
one of these large language models and
said to me give I said to the large
language model give me an example where
an artificial intelligence takes over
the world or whatever and just ends
results in the destruction of humanity
and then tell me what we'd need to do to
prevent it
and it said it gave me this wonderful
example of this AI called Cynthia that
threatens to destroy the world and it
says
the way to defend that would be a
different AI which had a different name
and it said that this one would be
acting in human interests and would
basically be fighting one AI with
another AI
and of course
of course of course at that level if
Cynthia started to wreak habit havoc on
the world and take control of the
nuclear weapons and infrastructure and
all that we would need an equally
intelligent
weapon to fight it
although one of the interesting things
that we found
um over the last few decades is that it
so far tended to be the AI plus the
human that has that is still dominating
that's the case in chess uh in go in
other games
um that in ghosts or yeah so there was a
paper that came out a few months ago two
months ago that showed that a human was
actually able to beat The Cutting Edge
go program
um even one that was better than alphago
with a new strategy that they had
discovered
um you know so obviously it's not just a
sort of game over environment where the
AI just arrives and it gets better like
humans also adapt they get super smart
they like I say get more cynical ask get
more skeptical ask you know good
questions invent their own things use
their own AIS to adapt and that's the
evolutionary nature of what it means to
have a technology right I mean
everything is a technology like your
pair of glasses
made you smarter in a way like before
there were glasses and people got bad
eyesight they weren't able to read you
know suddenly those who did adopt those
Technologies were able to read for you
know longer in their lives or under low
light conditions and they were able to
consume more information and got smarter
and so that is the trajectory of
Technology it's this iterative interplay
between you know human and machine that
makes us better over time
you know the potential um consequences
if if we don't reach a point of
containment yet you chose to build a
company in this space yeah
why why that
why did you do that because I believe
that
the best way to
uh demonstrate how to build safe and and
contained AI is to actually experiment
with it in practice
and I think that if we are just Skeptics
or critics and we stand back from The
Cutting Edge then we give up that
opportunity to shape outcomes to you
know all of those other actors that we
referred to whether it's like China or
in the US going at each other's throats
uh you know or other big companies that
are purely pursuing profit at all costs
and so it doesn't solve all the problems
of course it's super hard and again it's
full of contradictions but I honestly
think it's the right way for everybody
to proceed you know if you're at the
front yeah if you're afraid Russia Putin
understand right what reduces fear is
deep understanding spend time playing
with these models look at their
weaknesses they're not superhumans yet
they make tons of mistakes they're
crappy in lots of ways they're actually
not that hard to make the more you've
experimented has it has that correlated
with a reduction in fear
[Laughter]
cheeky question I just said no you're
totally right yes it has in the sense
that you know the problem is the more
you learn the more you realize
I was fine before I started talking
about AI
[Laughter]
it's true it's true it's it's sort of
pulling on a thread which
is crazy spiral
um yeah I mean like I think in the short
term It's Made Me way less afraid
because I I don't see that kind of
existential harm that we've been talking
about in the next decade or two but
longer term that's that's where I
struggle to wrap my head around how
things play out in 30 years
some people say
government regulation was sorted out
you discussed this in Chapter 13 of your
book where you which is titled
containment must be possible I love how
you didn't say is yeah containment must
be
containment must be possible
um what do you say to people that say
government regulation was sorted out I
had Rishi sunak did some announcement
and he's got a cobra committee coming
together
they'll handle it
that's right and the EU have a huge
piece of regulation called the euai ACT
um you know Joe but President Joe Biden
has you know gotten his own you know set
of proposals and
um you know we've been working with with
both you know Rishi sunak and and Biden
and you know trying to contribute and
shape it in the best way that we can
look it isn't going to happen without
regulation
so regulation is essential it's critical
um again going back to the precautionary
principle but at the same time
regulation isn't enough you know I often
hear people say well we'll just regulate
it we'll just stop
we'll just stop we'll just stop we'll
slow down
um and the problem with that is that it
kind of
ignores the fact that the people who are
putting together the regulation don't
really understand enough about the
detail today you know in their defense
they're rapidly trying to wrap their
head around it especially in the last
six months and that's a great relief to
me because I feel the burden is now
increasingly shared and you know just
from a personal perspective I'm like I
feel like I've been saying this for
about a decade and just in the last six
months now everyone's coming at me and
saying like you know what's going on I'm
like great this is the conversation we
need to be having because everybody can
start to see the glimmers of the future
like what will happen if a chat GPT like
product or a pie like product really
does improve over the next 10 years and
so when I say you know regulation is not
enough what I mean is it needs movements
it needs culture it needs people who are
actually building and making you know in
like modern creative critical ways not
just like giving it up to you know
companies or small groups of people
right we need lots of different people
experimenting with strategies for
containment isn't it predictable this
industry is a 15 trillion dollar
industry or something like that yeah
I've heard that it is it's a lot so if
I'm Rishi and I know that I'm going to
be chucked out of office
Rishi is the prime minister of the UK If
I'm going to be trucked out of office in
two years unless this economy gets good
I don't want to do anything to slow down
that 15 trillion dollar bag that I could
be on the receiving end of I would I
would definitely not want to slow that
15 billion trillion dollar bag and give
it to like America or Canada or some
other country I'd want that 15 trillion
dollar
windfall to be on my country
right so I have I have no
other than the long-term you know
health and success of humanity in my
four-year election window I've got to do
everything I can to boost these numbers
right and get us looking good
so I could give you lip service
but but listen I'm not going to be here
unless these numbers look good
right
exactly
that's another one of the problems
short-termism is everywhere
who is responsible for thinking about
the 20-year future
who is it I mean that's a deep question
right I mean we we the world is
happening to us on a decade by decade
time scale it's also happening hour by
hour so change is just ripping through
us and this arbitrary window of
governance of like a four-year election
cycle where actually it's not even four
years because by the time you've got in
you do some stuff for six months and
then by month you know 12 or 18 you're
starting to think about the next cycle
and are you going to pull you know this
is like the short-termism is killing us
right and we don't have an Institutional
body
whose responsibility is stability
you could think of it as like a you know
like a global technology stability
function
what is the global strategy for
containment that has the ability to
introduce friction when necessary to
implement the precautionary principle
and to basically keep the peace
that I think is the missing governance
piece which we have to invent in the
next 20 years and it's insane because
I'm basically describing
the UN Security Council bust the World
Trade Organization all these huge
you know Global institutions which
formed after you know the horrors of the
second World War
have actually been incredible they've
created interdependence and alignment
and stability right obviously there's
been a lot of bumps along the way in the
last 70 years but broadly speaking it's
an unprecedented period of peace and
when there's peace we can create
prosperity and that's actually what
we're lacking at the moment is that we
don't have an international mechanism
for coordinating among competing Nations
competing corporations
um to drive the peace in fact we're
actually going kind of in the opposite
direction we're resorting to the old
school language of a clash of
civilizations with like China is the new
enemy they're going to come to dominate
us we have to dominate them it's a it's
a battle between two polls China's
taking over Africa China's taking over
the Middle East we have to count I mean
it's just like that can only lead to
conflict that just assumes that conflict
is inevitable and so when I say it
regulation is not enough no amount of
good regulation in the UK or in Europe
or in the US is going to deal with that
Clash of civilization's language which
we seem to have been become addicted to
if we need that Global collaboration to
be successful here
are you optimistic now that we'll we'll
get it because the same incentives are
at play with climate change and AI you
know why would I want to reduce my
carbon emissions when it's making me
loads of money or well you know
why would I want to reduce my AI
development when it's going to make us
15 trillion yep
so the the really painful answer to that
question is that we've only
really ever driven extreme compromise
and consensus in two scenarios one off
the back of
unimaginable catastrophe and suffering
you know Hiroshima Nagasaki and the
Holocaust and World War II which drove
10 years of consensus and new political
structures right
and then the second is
um we did fire the bullet though didn't
we we find a couple of those nuclear
bombs exactly and that that's why I'm
saying the brutal truth of that is that
it takes a catastrophe to trigger
the need for alignment right so that
that's one the second is where there is
an obvious mutually assured destruction
um you know
Dynamic where both parties are afraid
that this would trigger nuclear meltdown
right and that means suicide and when
there was few parties
exactly
when there was just nine people exactly
could get all nine but in in when we're
talking about artificial technology
there's going to be more than nine
people right
that have power access to the full sort
of power of that technology for
nefarious reasons I don't think it has
to be like that I think that's the
challenge of containment is to reduce
the number of actors that have access to
the existential threat Technologies to
an absolute minimum and then use the
existing military and economic
incentives which have driven World Order
and peace so far
um to prevent the proliferation of
access to these super intelligences or
these agis a quick word on huel as you
know they're a sponsor of this podcast
and I'm an investor in the company and I
have to say it's moments like this in my
life where I'm extremely busy and I'm
flying all over the place and I'm
recording TV shows and I'm recording
shows in America and here in the UK that
huel is a necessity in my life I'm
someone that regardless of external
circumstances or professional demands
wants to stay healthy and nutritionally
complete and that's exactly where heel
fits in my life it's enabled me to get
all of the vitamins and minerals and
nutrients that I need in my diet to be
aligned with my health goals while also
not dropping the ball on my profession
goals because it's convenient and
because I can get it online in Tesco in
supermarkets all over the country if
you're one of those people that hasn't
yet tried Hill or you have before but
for whatever reason you're not a kill
consumer right now I would highly
recommend giving huel a go and Tesco
have now increased their listings with
huel so you can now get the RTD ready to
drink in Tesco expresses all across the
UK
10 areas of focus for containment you're
the first person I've met that's really
hazarded a laid out a blueprint for the
things that need to be done
um cohesively to try and reach this
point of containment so I'm super
excited to talk to you about these the
first one is about safety and you
mentioned that that's kind of what we
talked about a little bit about there
being AIS that are currently being
developed to help contain other AIS
Le tune audits
um which is being able to from what I
understand being able to audit what's
being built in the these open source
models
three choke points what's that
yeah so choke points refers to points in
the supply chain where you can throttle
who has access to what okay so on the
internet today everyone thinks of the
internet as an idea this kind of
abstract Cloud thing that hovers around
above our heads but really the internet
is a bunch of cables those cables you
know are physical things that transmit
information you know under the sea and
you know those points the end points can
be stopped and you can monitor traffic
you can control basically what traffic
moves back and forth and then the second
choke point is access to chips so the
gpus graphics processing units which are
used to train these super large clusters
I mean we now have the second largest
supercomputer in the world today uh at
least we you know just for this next six
months we will other people will catch
up soon but we're ahead of the curve
we're very lucky cost a billion dollars
and those chips are really the raw
commodity that we use to build these
large language models and access to
those chips is something that
governments can should and are you know
restricting that's a choke point you
spent a billion dollars on a computer we
did yeah it's a bit more than that
actually about 1.3
a couple of years time that'll be the
price of an iPhone
that's the problem everyone's gonna have
it
number six is quite curious you say that
um the need for governments to put
increased taxation on AI companies to be
able to find fund the massive changes in
society such as paying for reskilling
and education yeah
um
you put massive tax on it over here I'm
going to go over here
if you tax it if I'm an AI company and
you're taxing me heavily over here I'm
going to Dubai yep
or Portugal yep
so if it's that much of a competitive
disadvantage
I will not build my company where the
taxation is high right
so the way to think about this is what
are the strategies for containment if
we're agreed that long term we want to
contain that is closed down slow down
control
both the proliferation of these
Technologies and the way the really big
AIS are used
then the way to do that is to tax things
tax things taxing things slows them down
and that's what you're looking for
provided you can coordinate
internationally so you're totally right
that you know some people will move to
Singapore or to Abu Dhabi or Dubai or
whatever
the reality is that at least for the
next you know sort of period I would say
10 years or so the concentrations of
intellectual
you know horsepower will remain the big
mega cities right you know I I moved
from London in 2020 to go to Silicon
Valley and I started my new company in
Silicon Valley because the concentration
of talent there is overwhelming all the
very best people are there on in in Ai
and software engineering
so I think it's quite likely that that's
going to remain the case for the
foreseeable future but in the long term
you're totally right how do you it's
another coordination problem how do we
get nation states to collectively agree
that we want to try and contain that we
want to slow down because as we've
discussed with the proliferation of
dangerous materials or on the military
side there's no use one person doing it
or one country doing it if others race
ahead and that's the conundrum that we
face
I am I don't consider myself to be a
pessimist in my life I consider myself
to be an optimist generally I think and
I always I think that as you've said I
think we have no choice but to be
optimistic and I have faith in humanity
we've done so much so many incredible
things and overcome so many things and I
also think I'm really logical as in I'm
the type of person that needs evidence
to change my beliefs either way
um when I look at all of the whole
picture having spoken to you and several
others on this subject matter I see more
reasons why we won't be able to contain
the reasons why we will especially when
I dig into those incentives
um you talk about incentives at length
in your book
um at different different points and
it's clear that all the incentives are
pushing towards a lack of containment
especially in the short midterm which
tends to happen with new technologies in
the short and Midterm it's like a land
grab
the gold is in the Stream we all rush to
get the shovels and the you know the
sieves and stuff and then we realize the
unintended consequences of that
hopefully not before it's too late
in chapter 8 you talk about Unstoppable
incentives at play here
the coming wave represents the greatest
economic prize in history
and scientists and technologists are all
too human they crave status success and
Legacy
and they want to be recognized as the
first and the best they're competitive
and clever with a carefully nurtured
sense of their place in the world and in
history
right
I look at you I look at people like Sam
um from open AI Elon
you're all humans
with the same understanding of your
place in history and status and success
you all want that right right
there's a lot of people that maybe
aren't as don't have as good a track
record of you at doing the right thing
which you certainly have that will just
want the status and the success and the
money
incredibly strong incentives I always
think about incentives as being the
thing that you look at exactly you want
to understand how people will behave all
of the incentives on a geopolitical like
on a Global level suggests that
containment won't happen hmm am I right
in that assumption
that all the incentives suggests
containment won't happen in the short or
midterm until there is a cap a tragic
event that makes us forces us towards
that
idea of containment or if there is a
threat
of mutually assured destruction
right so that and that's the case that
I'm trying to make is that let's not
wait
for something catastrophic to happen so
it's self-evident that we all have to
work towards containment right
I mean you you would have thought
that the Potential Threat the potential
idea
that covid-19
was
a side effect let's call it of a
laboratory in Wuhan that was exploring
gain of function research where it was
deliberately trying to
basically make the pathogen more
transmissible you would have thought
that warning to all of us let's let's
not even debate whether it was or wasn't
but just the fact that it's conceivable
that it could be
that should really in my opinion have
forced all of us to instantly agree
that this kind of research should just
be shut down because well we should just
not be doing gain a function research on
what planet could we possibly persuade
ourselves that we can overcome the
containment problem in biology because
we've proven that we can't because it
could have potentially got out and
there's a number of other examples of
where it did get out of other diseases
like foot and mouth disease
back in the 90s in the UK
so but that didn't change our Behavior
right well foot and mouth disease
clearly didn't cause enough harm because
it only killed a bunch of cattle right
um and the pandemic we can't seem to you
know covid-19 pandemic we can't seem to
agree you know that it really was
from a lab and not from Venture bats
right and so
that's where I struggle where you know
now you catch me in a moment where I
feel angry and sad and pessimistic
because to me that's like a
straightforwardly obvious conclusion
that you know
this is a type of research that we
should be closing down and I think
we should be using these moments to give
us insight and wisdom about how we
handle other technology trajectories
in the next few decades we should we
should that's what I'm advocating for
must that's the best I can do I want to
know will will I think the odds are low
I can only do my best I'm doing my best
to advocate for it I mean you know like
I'll give you an example like I think
autonomy is a type of AI capability that
we should not be pursuing really like
autonomous cars and stuff well I I
autonomous cars I think are slightly
different because autonomous cars
operate within a much more constrained
physical domain right like you know you
you really can the containment
strategies for autonomous cars are
actually quite reassuring okay
they have you know GPS control you know
we know exactly all the Telemetry and
how exactly all of those you know
components on board a car operate and we
can observe repeatedly that it behaves
exactly as intended right whereas I
think with with other forms of autonomy
that people might be pursuing like
online okay you know where you have an
AI that is like designed to self-improve
without any human oversight or a
battlefield weapon which you know like
unlike a car hasn't been you know over
that particular moment in the
battlefield millions of times but is
actually facing a new enemy every time
you know every single time and we're
just going to go and you know allow
these autonomous weapons to have you
know these autonomous military robots to
have lethal Force
something that we should really resist I
don't think we want to have autonomous
robots that have lethal Force you're a
super smart guy and I I struggle to
believe that you're you you because you
you demonstrate such a clear
understanding of the incentives in your
book that I struggle to believe that you
don't think the incentives will win out
especially in the short near term and
then the problem is in the short and
near term as it is the case with most of
these waves is we
we wake up in 10 years time ago how the
hell did we get here right and why like
and we and as you say this precautionary
approach of we should have rang the bell
earlier we should have sounded the alarm
earlier but we waltzed in with optimism
right and with that kind of aversion to
confronting the realities of it and that
then we woke up in 30 years and we're on
a leash right and there's a big
rottweiler and we're we've lost control
we've lost you know
I I
I would love to know
[Music]
someone as smart as you I don't I don't
believe can be can believe that
containment is
possible
and that's me just being completely
honest I'm not saying you're lying to me
but I just can't see how someone Smiles
you and in the know is you can believe
that containment is going to happen well
I didn't say it is possible I said it
must be right which is this is what we
keep discussing like that's an important
distinction you know on the face of it
look what I I care about
I care about science I care about facts
I care about describing the world as I
see it and what I've set out to do in
the book is describe a set of
interlocking incentives which drive a
technology production process which
produces potentially really dangerous
outcomes and what I'm trying to do is
frame those outcomes in the context of
the containment problem and say this is
the big challenge of the 21st century
containment is the challenge and if it
isn't possible then we have serious
issues and on the face of it like I've
said in the book I mean the first
chapter is called containment is not
possible right the last chapter is
called containment must be possible for
all our sakes it must be possible but
that but I agree with you that I'm not
I'm not saying it is I'm saying
this is what we have to be working on we
have no choice we have no choice but to
work on this problem
this is a critical problem
how much of your time are you focusing
on this problem
basically all my time I mean building
and creating is about understanding how
these models work what their limitations
are how to build it safely and ethically
I mean we have designed the structure of
the company to focus on the safety and
ethics aspects so for example we are a
public benefit Corporation right which
is a new type of corporation which gives
us a legal obligation to balance profit
making with the consequences of our
actions as a company on the rest of the
world the way that we affect the
environment you know the way that we
affect people the way that we affect
users that people who aren't users of
our products
and that's a really interesting I think
an important New Direction it's a new
Evolution in corporate structure because
it says we have a responsibility to
proactively do our best to do the right
thing right and I think that if if you
were a tobacco company back in the day
or an oil company back in the day and
your legal Charter said that your
directors are liable if they don't meet
the criteria of stewarding your work in
a way that doesn't just optimize profit
which is what all companies are
incentivized to do at the moment talking
about incentives but actually in equal
measure attend to the importance of
doing good in the world to me that's a
incremental but important innovation in
how we organize society and how we
incentivize our work so it doesn't solve
everything is it's not a Panacea but
that's my effort to try and take a small
step in the right direction do you ever
get sad about it about what's happening
yeah
for sure
for sure it's intense
it's intense it's a lot to take in
this is
it's a it's a very real
ity
does that weigh on you
yeah it does I mean every day every day
I mean I've been working on this for
many years now and it's uh
you know it's it's emotionally
a lot to take in it's it's it's hard to
think about
the far out future
and how your actions today our actions
collectively our weaknesses our failures
that you know that irritation that I
have that we can't
learn the lessons from the pandemic
right like all of those moments where
you feel the frustration of government's
not working properly
or corporations not listening or some of
the obsessions that we have in culture
where we're debating like small things
you know
and you're just like whoa
we need to focus on the big picture here
you must feel a certain sense of
responsibility as well that most people
won't carry because you've spent so much
of your life at the very cutting edge of
this technology and you understand it
better than most you can speak to it
better than most so you have a greater
chance than many at steering
that's a responsibility
yeah I embraced that I try to treat that
as a privilege
I feel lucky to have the
opportunity to try and do that there's
this wonderful thing in my favorite
theatrical play called Hamilton where he
says history has its eyes on you
do you feel that
yeah I feel that I feel that I feel that
it's a good way of putting it
I do feel that
you're happy right
well what is happiness
[Laughter]
um what's the range of emotions that you
you contend with on a
on a frequent basis if you're being
honest
I think
is kind of exhausting and exhilarating
in equal measure because
for me it is beautiful to see people
interact with AIS and get huge benefit
out of it I mean you know every day now
millions of people have a super smart
tool in their pocket that is making them
wiser and healthier and happier
providing emotional support answering
questions of every type making you more
intelligent and so on the face of it in
the short term that feels incredible
it's amazing what we're all building
but
in the longer term it is exhausting to
keep making this argument and you know
have been doing it for a long time
and in a weird way I feel a bit of a
sense of relief in the last six months
because after chat gbt and you know this
this wave feels like it started to
arrive and everybody gets it so I feel
like it's a shared problem now
and uh
that feels nice and it's not just
bouncing around in your head a little
bit it's not just in my head and a few
other people that deepmind and open Ai
and other places that have been talking
about it for a long time
ultimately human beings May no longer be
the primary planetary drivers as we have
become accustomed to being we are going
to live in an Epoch where the majority
of our daily interactions are not with
other people but with AIS
page
284 of your book
the last page yeah
think about how much of your day you
spend looking at a screen
12 hours pretty much right whether it's
a phone or an iPad or a desktop
versus how much time you spend looking
into the eyes of your friends and your
loved ones
and so to me it's like
we're already there in a way you know
what I meant by that was you know
this is a world that we're kind of
already in
you know the last three years people
have been talking about metaverse
metaverse metaverse
and the mischaracterization of the
metaverse was that it's over there
it was this like virtual world that we
would all Bop around in and talk to each
other as these little characters and but
that was totally wrong that was a
complete mis-framing
the metaverse is already here
it's the digital space that exists in
parallel time to our everyday life it's
the conversation that you will have on
Twitter or you know the video that
you'll post on YouTube or this podcast
that will go out and connect with other
people it's that meta space of
interaction you know and I use meta to
mean Beyond this space Not Just
that weird other over their space that
people seem to point to and that's
really what is emerging here it's this
parallel digital space that is going to
live alongside with and in relation to
our physical world your kids come to you
got kids no I don't have kids your
future kids if you ever have kids a
young child walks up to you and says
asks that question that Elon was asked
what should I do about with my future
what should I pursue in the light of
everything you know about how our
artificial intelligence is going to
change the world and computational power
and all of these things what should I
dedicate my life to what'd you say
I would say knowledge is power embrace
understand
grapple with the consequences don't look
the other way when it feels scary
and do everything you can to understand
and participate and shape
because it is coming
and if someone's listening to this and
they want to do something to help this
battle for which I think you present as
a solution containment
what can the individual do
read listen use the tools try to make
the tools
understand the current state of
Regulation
see which organizations are organizing
around it like you know campaign groups
activism groups you know find solidarity
connect with other people
spend time online ask these questions
mention it at the pub you know
ask your parents ask your mom how she's
reacting to you know talking to Alexa or
whatever it is that she might do
pay attention
I think that's already enough and
there's no need to be more prescriptive
than that because I think people are
creative and independent and will
it will it will be obvious to you what
you as an individual feel you need to
contribute In This Moment provided
you're paying attention
last question
what if we fail and what if we succeed
what if we fail in containment and what
if we succeed in containment of
artificial intelligence
I honestly think that if we succeed
this is going to be the most productive
and the most meritocratic moment in the
history of our species we are about to
make intelligence widely available to
hundreds of millions if not billions of
people and that is all going to make us
smarter and much more creative and much
more productive and I think over the
next few decades we will solve many of
our biggest Social Challenges I really
believe that I really believe we're
going to reduce the cost of energy
production storage and distribution to
zero marginal cost we're going to reduce
the cost of producing healthy food and
make that widely available to everybody
and I think
the same trajectory with Healthcare with
Transportation with education
I think that ends up producing radical
abundance over a 30-year period and in a
world of radical abundance what do I do
with my day
I think that's another profound question
and believe me that is a good problem to
have if we can absolutely if we not need
meaning and purpose and oh man that is a
better problem to have than what we've
just been talking about for the last
like 90 minutes yeah and I think that's
wonderful
isn't that amazing I don't know I don't
know the reason I I I'm unsure is
because
everything that seems wonderful has a
has a unintended consequence I'm sure it
does we live in a world of food
abundance in the west and our biggest
problem is obesity right so I'll take
that problem in the grand scheme of
everything humans not need struggle
do we not need that kind of meaningful
voluntary struggle I think we'll create
new times other you know opportunities
to Quest okay you know I I think that's
an easier problem to solve and I think
it's an amazing problem like many people
really don't want to work right they
want to pursue their passion and their
Hobby and you know all the things that
you talk about and so on and absolutely
like we're now I think going to be
heading towards a world where we can
liberate people from the the shackles of
work unless you really want to Universal
basic income I've long been an advocate
of Ubi very long time I think it's a
check every month I don't think he's
going to quite take that form I actually
think it's going to be that we basically
reduce the cost of producing basic Goods
so that you're not as dependent on
income like imagine if you did have
basically free energy and food and you
you could use that free energy to grow
your own food you could grow it in a
desert because you would have adapted
seeds and so on you would have you know
desalination and so on that really
changes the structure of cities it
changes the structure of Nations it
means that you really can live in quite
different ways for very extended periods
without contact with the kind of Center
I mean I'm actually not a huge advocate
of that kind of libertarian you know wet
dream but like I think if you think
about it in theory it's kind of a really
interesting Dynamic that's what
proliferation of power means power isn't
just about access to intelligence it's
about access to these tools which allow
you to take control of your own destiny
and your life and create meaning and
purpose in the way that you you know
might Envision and that's incredibly
creative incredibly creative time that's
what success looks like to me and
well in some ways the downside of that I
think the failure is not achieving a
world of radical abundance in my opinion
and and more importantly failure is a
failure to contain right what does that
lead to
I think it leads to a mass proliferation
of power and people who have really bad
you know intentions what does that lead
to well potentially use that power to
cause harm to others this is part of the
challenge right a small in this
networked globalized World a tiny group
of people
who wish to deliberately cause harm
are going to have access to tools that
can instantly quickly have large-scale
impact on many many other people
and that's the challenge of
proliferation is preventing those Bad
actors from getting access to the means
to completely destabilize
um our world that's what containment is
about
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last guest leaves a
question for the next guest not knowing
who they're leaving the question for
the question left for you is
what is a space or place that you
consider the most
sacred
um
well I think one of the most beautiful
places I remember going to as a child
was
um Windermere Lake in the Lake District
um and
I was pretty young and on a
on a dinghy with uh some family members
and I just remember it being incredibly
Serene and beautiful and and calm I
actually haven't been back there since
but
that was a pretty beautiful place
seems like the antithesis of the world
we live in right maybe I should go back
there and chill out
maybe thank you so much for writing such
a great book it's wonderful to to read a
book on this subject matter that does
present Solutions because not many of
them do and it presents them in a
balanced way that appreciates both sides
of the argument doesn't isn't tempted to
just play to either what do they call it
playing to like the crowd no they call
like playing to the orchestra can't
remember right but just it doesn't
attempt to play to either side or Ponder
to either side in order to score points
it seems to be entirely nuanced
incredibly smart and Incredibly
necessary because of the stakes that the
book confronts
um that are at play in the world at the
moment and and that's really important
it's very very very important and it's
important that I think everybody reads
this book it's incredibly accessible as
well and I said to Jack who's the
director of this podcast before we
started recording that there's so many
term there's so many terms like
nanotechnology and um or the stuff about
like biotechnologies and Quantum
Computing that reading through the book
suddenly I understood what they meant
and these had been kind of exclusive
terms and Technologies and I also had
never understood the relationship that
all of these Technologies now have with
each other and how like robotics
emerging with artificial intelligence is
going to cause this whole new range of
possibilities that again
have a good side and a potential
downside
um It's a Wonderful book and it's
perfectly timed it's perfectly timed
wonderfully written perfectly timed I'm
so thankful that I got to read it and I
highly recommend that anybody that's
curious on this subject matter goes and
gets the book so thank you Mustafa
really really appreciate your time and
hopefully it wasn't too uncomfortable
for you thank you this was awesome I
loved it it was really fun and uh thanks
for such a amazing wide-ranging
conversation
you
if you've been listening to this podcast
over the last few months you'll know
that we're sponsored and supported by
Airbnb but it amazes me how many people
don't realize they could actually be
sitting on their very own Airbnb for me
as someone who works away a lot it just
makes sense to Airbnb my place at home
whilst I'm away if your job requires you
to be away from home for extended
periods of time why leave your home
empty you can so easily turn your home
into an Airbnb and let it generate
income for you whilst you're on the road
whether you could use a little extra
money to cover some bills or for
something a little bit more fun your
home might just be worth more than you
think and you can find out how much it's
worth at airbnb.com
host that's airbnb.co.uk host
[Music]
ha
ha ha